if you wanted to operate
I can one even operate
if you want to operate
holy crap Aquaman footage let's break
this down I lose that a couple times
just so you get a better look at it
because it's super quick it's a visual
effects test so it's not like actually
Jason Momoa swimming through water but
it's for Justice League and obviously
it's going to inform the look or some of
the look of what's going on in the
Aquaman movie so even though each of the
directors has their own thing going on
in the spin-off movies a lot of this
starts with what Zack Snyder started so
like they're not going to completely
redesign Atlantis after we see it during
Justice League but that's basically what
this implies is that we're in Atlantis
and he's swimming up to ocean master or
this could be a statue but I think the
hats up here is the helmet it looks very
much like ocean masters helmet so
there's a new round of the DC giveaway
just because it's such a big deal we'll
say for a copy of injustice to so all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
freaking out about Aquaman stuff I feel
like the trailer is right around the
corner too because a lot of people got
to visit Warner Brothers and see how
they did this CG because it's sort of
like a real-time rendering thing in the
way that they did that Deathstroke
costume test with Joe Manganiello a
while ago that video that Ben Affleck
posted that was actually a costume test
that Joe Manganiello himself was doing
they did the same thing on spider-man
homecoming when they posted this
behind-the-scenes video of their like
real-time rendering with spider-man was
doing in this giant green-screen stage
so if you guys don't know what's going
on with Justice League Aquaman's stuff
we're going to meet the character we'll
get a look at the universe they'll
probably tease some of the big conflicts
that are happening because there has to
be a reason for Aquaman to not want to
join the Justice League he seems really
reluctant when we saw him in that
comic-con trailer the Zack Snyder posted
last year like the main conflict with
ocean master especially in the comics or
if you saw the throne of Atlantis movie
is that ocean master seizes control of
Atlantis because he is Aquaman's
half-brother they have the same mother
Atlanta but Aquaman's father is from the
land ocean masters father is a member of
the Royal Guard that his mother was
forced to remarry after she came back
after giving birth to Aquaman so it's
very Game of Thrones the person who is
rightfully heir doesn't necessarily want
the Iron Throne of Atlantis
but the person who is on the throne is
absolutely terrible wants to see harm
comes
to the surface world we're going to
taste for that at the beginning of
Justice League because it looks like
he's fully aware of his powers and his
heritage but he's not married to Mira
he's not king of Atlantis in the teaser
poster was all about unite to seven as
in the Seven Kingdoms of Atlantis so I
did a separate video explaining the new
52 storyline the rise of the seven seas
there's only three kingdoms of Atlantis
right now in the comics they imply that
they're going to be a bunch of lost
kingdoms that will be rising later that
storyline kind of got pushed
so there's trench Zeb oh it's or tuff in
an alternate dimension invented Atlantis
so you have all these different forces
so ocean master is manipulating them all
very Game of Thrones style in Aquaman
has to deal with this while also dealing
with all this Justice League stuff
that's going on and we have mother Box
stuff that's going on too so the really
cool thing about the mother boxes is
that they're using them as the makeup as
the infinity gems the thing that
Darkseid wants Steppenwolf to go to
earth to get so long ago the way they
explained the backstory for Justice
League is that there was a war with
Darkseid he was defeated through an
alliance of the Atlanteans the Amazon in
another like mysterious ancient one that
they don't fully explain three mother
boxes were left behind
so one of them now we know is inside
cyborg he's basically part mother box
now then another one went to Atlantis
and the other one went with the Amazon
so they'll pop up during the spin-off
movies but we'll learn all about that
when we get to Justice League the
probably teased some of it in the
trailer and then when we get to the
Aquaman solo movie I'm expecting
something closer to throne of Atlantis
like I got all these problems with my
own people under the sea I'm going to
put a bookmark on that while I deal with
this giant space threat which seems way
more critical then I'll come back to
this later
[Music]
welcome bastard is Atlantis everything
you dreamed of brother or in your dream
were you on the throne we will cleanse
the puppet soon they shall know that our
time has come I will bring our world
so they are in pre-production for
Aquaman right now
they cast Black Manta it's this actor
here everybody's wondering what his
helmets going to look like like please
Jesus if you change anything don't
change the comic-book helmet too much
it's totally cool if he walks around
without the helmet on for a while but as
long as there's one day battle with him
wearing it it'd be so awesome and I know
all you young justice fans out there are
wondering about Aqualad James Wan did
confirm there is no Aqualad this plan
for the movie so if he shows up it'll be
like way down the road but that doesn't
mean that he'll never show up well let
me know what you guys think about all
this I know it's kind of blurry but
they'll release the high-res trailer in
the next month or two so we'll get a
much better look at all the different
characters from where they pop up in the
movie let me know in the comments is
there any bonus videos you guys want me
to do for Justice League or Aquaman
related stuff I feel like Aquaman right
now is going to be one of the standout
characters in Justice League that's what
most of the behind-the-scenes rumblings
have said is it Aquaman is like the
badass it's going to turn everybody
around so initially people were like the
flash is going to be so awesome in this
movie I love how people now are like no
Aquaman Aquaman is going to be the guy
that everybody loves but there's been a
bunch of craziness in the DC Universe
with all the Batman Nightwing stuff that
just got announced I totally think that
Justice League is going to be 100
percent fine Ben Affleck will stay I
know everybody's wondering like what
happens if it doesn't do well I think
it'll totally do fine I haven't seen
Wonder Woman yet but I think that'll be
fine too
Justice League is the thing that
everybody's waiting for though so I
think what's going to happen is is we'll
get a Wonder Woman trailer before we get
Justice League but there'll be some new
Wonder Woman really soon so that means
Justice League also right around the
corner so no worries there are so much
comic-book stuff happening this spring
there's going to be all kinds of Marvel
movie stuff all kinds of DC movie stuff
and that doesn't say anything about the
TV shows as the comic books themselves
what's going to happen next is I'll post
my arrow episode video Thursday morning
then I have Marvel movie stuff so
congratulations to last week's injustice
giveaway winner Michael Ross please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details there was a new brand that
started in this video I'll announce the
winner when I post my next DC movie
video while you wait for that you can
click here for that other Aquaman video
explain that backstory and you can click
here for the Guardians trailer
so much for watching let's high-five
I'll see you guys in the next video